in the community she called home this
was a chance to remember those who knew
olivia pratt corbell the neighbors and
friends
in the church where she would have taken
holy communion in the next year
away from the cameras olivia's mother
was among the congregation we can only
imagine what the family continues to
endure but this was those around them
coming together in a show of support
group is a very difficult thing and it
will take them a long long long time to
never come to terms with what's going on
but there will certainly be able to suck
it in and say that they're not on their
own people here will show an invisible
support
the investigation continues police say
they're grateful to those who've come
forward with information but that just
because arrests have been made it
doesn't mean they need that information
any less
close to the scene of the murder
officers were carrying out another
search the firearm used still hasn't
been found
for more than a week now this community
has wrestled with the horror of what
happened to olivia the questions and the
anger and the disbelief but this was a
moment of reflection a moment to mourn
the loss of one young life and the
heartbreak of one family
i hope that the family have gained some
strength from seeing exactly how many
people have come out this evening and i
know the school have got further things
that are going to happen over the next
couple of days so hopefully the family
will get
um
a little bit of strength from that
knowing that everybody is behind them
100
it's just a shame that
something like this happens has to
happen to bring a community together
and it's really really sad
i mean i think
you know the young children growing up
today in a place in a cruel cruel world
and i just hope that they get them next
week children will return to olivia's
school without her but with support on
hand so next week is an opportunity to
find out
just how deep the impact has been on the
children and what level of support each
child will need some will need more than
others some will know more than others
they queued to sign a book of condolence
in what the bishop called a dark hour
for this community and one still with so
many questions greg milam sky news
liverpool